paris moutier be temps historienne
hauteur de la shoah dans les territoires
soviétiques occupaient aux éditions
passées composé bon soir marie vautier
habitants on va aborder avec vous
peut-être importe cette deuxième guerre
mondiale qui n'est pas connu
nécessairement par tout le monde
nous sommes donc en 1941 en pleine
opération barbarossa la shoah commençant
territoire soviétique
expliquez-nous comment cela se met en
place
alors dès le 22 juin 1941 des premiers
massacres de juifs commence dans les
territoires soviétique occupés et
contrairement à l'ouest ce sont les
bourreaux qui vont aller aux victimes et
non l inverse c'est à dire que des
milliers de sites d'exécution vont se
déployer à l'est des unités mobiles dont
les einsatzgruppen vont massacrer plus
de un tiers des victimes de la shoah
alors quand vous parlez de alsace
gruppen ce sont des commando d'assassins
c'est bien cela explique mais nous qui
sont pile alors ils sont environ 3000
répartis en quatre groupes
le premier groupe qui va balayer les
pays baltes et se rendent jusqu'à
leningrad
le deuxième qui lui va massacrer les
juifs de biélorussie
le troisième et le quatrième le cld qui
vont massacrer les juifs d'ukraine et
c'est finalement c'est 3000 hommes vont
tuer +22 je dirais 800 milles
personne en même pas un an alors ils
sont hors de l'armée sézanne stan
gruppen tout en étant partie de l'armée
tout en faisant partie de l'armée
d'occupation alors il sort alors ils
sont indépendants de l'armée bien
entendu d'un envoyé des rapports avec à
la wehrmacht pour être sûr qu'ils ne
vont pas empiéter sur les terrains
d'opérations militaires
mais sinon ils ont toute autonomie pour
tuer les opposants désigné auparavant
par heydrich et amber qui sont leurs
chèvres et directe et qui vont leur
désigner les juifs les communistes les
membres des partis communistes comme les
premières cibles dont qui en gros il se
glisse finalement au même ordre que les
ss c'est ça tout à fait il
il appartiendrait sacha qui est
directement présidée par reinhard
heydrich et leur mission est
véritablement d'éliminer tous les
opposants de l'arrière front les
premières victimes seront des hommes
juifs massivement mais dès le mois
d'août 1941 des femmes et des enfants
juifs vont faire partie des victimes
et je dirais qu'à partir de septembre
octobre 1941 les massacres de juifs
des familles entières sera systématique
à l'est alors pour avoir une vision
globale des choses à combien de morts
estime-t-on la shoah en union soviétique
occuper 10 ans entre 2 et 2,5 millions
de juifs ont été tués sur ces
territoires
alors avec quels moyens et quel objectif
la politique génocidaire nazis s'est
elle mise en place à ce moment là est ce
que l'armée ait appris une plate
bien entendu la wehrmacht a fourni un
appui logistique considérable aux alsace
gruppen mais il ya aussi les bataillons
de police qui ont participé et comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer les populations
locales la police locale et une main
d'oeuvre très importante a été
réquisitionné pour creuser les fausses
combler les fossés transportait les
victimes jusqu'au site d'exécution
c'était toute une occasion en or
ganisation vous imaginez à l'échelle
d'un territoire pour tuer 2 5 millions
de juifs alors à partir de 1942 se met
en place l'opération
1005 expliquez-nous ce que sait quel est
son objectif
à partir de janvier 1942 les soviétiques
commence à parler dans la presse des
massacres commis par les par les nazis
du côté des allemands on se rend compte
que les cadavres dans des fosses
communes peuvent être un véritable outil
de propagande pour les soviétiques et il
donnerait une image désastreuse de
l'allemagne en pleine guerre si les
soviétiques venette à découvrir ces
charniers c'est pour ça qu'à partir de
juillet 42 ans va missionner un ancien
membre des commandos paul blobel pour
trouver une solution
il va mener une politique de des termes
en décor et ensuite ces corps seront
brûlées dans d'immenses muchez par des
commandos composé de main d'oeuvre juive
qui sont bien entendu exécuté par la
suite mais tous les charniers n'ont pas
été ouverts et détruit pour beaucoup ils
sont
ils ont profité de la vence de l'armée
rouge et ont pu être préservés et
ensuite l'armée rouge a pu faire état de
ces fosses communes alors l'ennemi vous
le dites dans votre livre c'est dès le
mois de juin 1941 le judéo bolchevisme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que dès le début de l'opération
barbarossa dont on parlait l'armée
d'occupation allemande confond à un mode
de gouvernement avec avec une religion
alors disons que dès le départ les
soldats les membres de l'instance
européenne de bataille n police savent
clairement que lemmy c'est les juifs
parce que les juifs gouvernent l'union
soviétique et en s'en prenant aux juifs
on va s'en prendre finalement aux
fondements mêmes de l'union soviétique
qui devrait s'effondrer
finalement pourquoi on parle très peu de
ce pan de l'histoire on parle on connaît
davantage une autre partie de l'histoire
et peut justement ces morts sur le
territoire de l'union soviétique à la
raison pendant des décennies ces
archives n'ont pas été accessibles pour
les chercheurs de l'ouest mais à la
faveur de la chute de l'union soviétique
nous avons pu avoir accès à des
centaines de milliers de pages
d'archivés qui ont été produits par
l'union soviétique notamment par une
commission denquête créé en 1942 chargé
de documenter tous ces crimes commis à
l'est dont chaque village et cette
commission a permis de documenter
vraiment les crimes delestre et comment
vous les avez trouvés tous ces documents
ce bien que les nazis effectivement
faisait le récit de leurs massacres dans
des ondées récit dans les écoles alors
quelques rapports des intérêts coupables
nous sont parvenues mais disons que
toutes les archives officielles ont été
quasiment détruites
en revanche nous est restée les
correspondances intimes
les photographies personnelles en fait
tous les documents personnels pour
beaucoup ont été récupérés par l'armée
rouge lors de la libération des villas
quelle a été la réaction des autorités
soviétiques après la guerre est ce qu'il
y a eu des procès comme évidemment celui
qu'on connaît très bien le procès de
nuremberg gay ce qu'il y à eut alors
juger mais oui dès l'année 1943 alors
que la guerre est
loin d'être finie à krasnodar se tient
le premier procès le collaborateur nazis
ils sont jugés pour trahison et il y
aura jusqu'à la chute de l'union
soviétique dossier 50000 condamnation de
collaborateurs aujourd'hui est-ce que ce
devoir de mémoire qui a également en
europe avec la choisit on la retrouve
également dans ces pays qui ont eu ces
morts je dirais que ce cette mémoire est
aussi associée aux autres victimes du
nazisme sur ce territoire qu'elle ne
faut pas oublier que les populations
locales et les prisonniers de guerre ont
payé un très lourd tribut de la guerre
et de l'occupation nazie par exemple un
biélorusse sur trois a été tué pendant
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale il
faut replacer aussi les choses dans le
contexte aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
éducation / sur ce point dans les livres
d'histoire de ces pays là disons que
dans certains pays comme la biélorussie
on entretient véritablement cette
mémoire les lieux les sites d'exécution
son mémorial ise je dirais que les
choses sont plutôt bien fait
merci beaucoup marie gautier me tendent
à rester avec mon directe ur rt france
merci m